welcome back located downtown the
cornish pasty company is rich in flavor
and also history thank you to cisco for
sponsoring this segment and for bringing
the owner john bender and manager
nicholas thomaston into into the kitchen
today welcome you guys thanks man okay
so what is a cornish pasty
so it's uh traditional english uh
handheld meat pie that
dates back to like the mid-1200s
and it's from uh the southwest um part
of england so i was told too is this
true that miners would use these because
it was easy to make
you have your dough you just put
anything inside this thing you close it
up you get out of the mines and you open
it up you get a hot meal ready to go
correct yeah like the the miners wives
would would make them they would uh wrap
them up
take them down there and they could eat
it they would stay warm for a few hours
so by the time they're ready to eat them
they'd be ready to go ready to go and
then you have the the crimp on top and
they would throw that crimp away because
of the
all the like the poisoning the kind like
a handle to eat it yeah and then you
would throw that away
so what you didn't poison yourself with
with your mind on your hands and
everything sure i've been your
restaurant many times uh and i love it i
love the the cuban one you have but you
have 40 different varieties what are
some of the ones you brought for us
today so
uh starting with the traditional one we
have the augie that's just going to be
your your standard meat and potatoes
what you would actually get if you were
in cornwall
and then we we took the concept and we
did many different things we have a
we have a cheeseburger one it's bacon
cheeseburger with mushrooms grilled
onions
we even have
french fries inside of it
we have a reuben uh with our house made
sauerkraut
pastrami
swiss and corned beef and then we even
do a bunch of vegan ones and we have a
vegan cottage pie up there i noticed he
said vegan and vegetarian options on the
menu yeah about a third of our menu is
is vegan or vegetarian now this one i
have here is is this is this new menu
because this is your thanksgiving
special this one used to be a special
but it was so popular we run it year
round now and that is uh
turkey stuffing and sweet potatoes i'm
going to get served with a side of
cranberry and our red wine gravy
should i pick it up with a handle
i'm going to take it hard yeah just pick
it yeah yeah
oh wow
wow
thank you
and then we have some
we have our pasta salad
and then also we have a
tandoori wings
with uh indian curry spices
and then our parliament wings with our
house-made wing sauce and blue cheese
let me tell you this if you were to
create fall and put it in food this is
fall right here this is delicious yeah
this is perfect perfect watch i can
envision myself eating one of these
watching a football game or something
that's perfect for uh for thanksgiving
watching some football yeah forget about
my mom
in the kitchen all afternoon just get
one of these and be good to go yeah you
can actually uh you can actually order
them par baked
where you take it home and you get in
you can cook you get to cook it yourself
you guys thank you so much for joining
us we appreciate it thank you to cisco
for sponsoring this segment cornish
pasty company located at east charleston
in maine call them at
702-862-4538 or
visit
cornishpastycompany.com rocky yeah i'm